[Applause]
I got to say that's a full-circle moment
for me and I just like to take a moment
to thank Jesus and the ancestors and do
a little happy dance hello because I
brought 20 girls to the United States
I've been to this is my 19th and final
graduation today 19 graduations in the
past 3 years
and what's interesting is I know 17
graduations and to Becca laureates
because I had three twice in one day in
3 different cities and couldn't get to
all three cities in one day so to be
here and have you beautiful police' I
know where you've come from I know what
the blossoming has been here at CC it
gives me such pride and fills me with
such joy to see you becoming the woman
that you are so thank you for that
beautiful introduction and thank you
full circle moment Thank You president
chief and how teefin taller thank you so
much good morning class of 2019
I'm here for police' and I'm here for
you this is my second time two years ago
I was here one of my other daughters a
Vakeel a graduated two years ago from
CeCe and I was back there freezing like
everybody else is right now including a
gentleman I saw in the elevator who said
don't mention my name
I will not who'd gone back in to change
clothes and I thought I'm gonna hide I'm
a cute little white dress and then I
thought I'm gonna freeze my buns off so
thank you gentlemen in the elevator I
especially appreciate and resonate with
your class motto the quote from Angela
Davis which says you have to act as if
it's possible to radically transform the
world and you have to do that all the
time I'm here to tell you that you
actually do get to transform the world
every day by your actions small steps
lead to big accomplishments and I'm here
to tell you that your life isn't some
big break like everybody thinks it is
they're waiting on the big break
it's actually about taking one
significant life-transforming step at a
time so you can pick a problem literally
any problem the list is long because
there's gun violence and economic
inequality and there's media bias and
the homeless need opportunity and the
addicted need treatment and the dreamers
need protection the prison system needs
to be reformed the social safety net
needs saving misogyny needs to stop
and the truth is you cannot fix
everything but what you can do here and
now is make a decision because life is
about decisions and the decision is that
you will use your life in service you
will be in service to life and you will
speak up you will show up you will stand
up you will sit in you will volunteer
you will vote you will shout out you
will help you will Linda Han you will
offer your talent and your kindness
however you can and you will radically
transform whatever moment you're in
which leads to bigger moments because
the truth is success is it's it's a
process you can ask anybody who's been
successful I just passed and and saw
walking up the lane here successful
entrepreneur and restaurateur Danny
Meyer who's sitting back there with his
family there
Charles is graduating today
but the years of truth ask Danny or
anybody who's successful you go to any
one of his restaurants Shake Shack love
it
Union Square Gramercy Tavern and you
will be impressed by not only the food
which you have to do that if your
restaurant but by the radical
hospitality and service and so service
is not just about when you're getting
served
it's truly everything you know I started
my talk show I was just so happy to be
on television and I was one day
interviewing members of the Ku Klux Klan
I thought I was interviewing them so
that I could expose their vitriol to the
world
I saw them giving signals to each other
in the audience and I thought hmm
something's going on here and I realize
they were using me they were using the
platform for themselves so I said to my
producers afterwards I'm not gonna do
that anymore then we did a show where
someone was embarrassed and it was my
fault I was responsible for the
embarrassment for some crazy reason we
talked a man who was cheating on his
wife to come to the show with the woman
he was cheating on and his wife and he
said yes and while they're on live
television he says to his wife that his
girlfriend is pregnant that happened on
my watch
and when that happened shortly after I
had interviewed the Klan and experienced
that I said I'm not gonna do that again
so I started to ask the question how can
I use this show to not just be a show
but to allow it to be a service to the
viewer and that question of how did we
serve the viewer transform the show and
because we asked that question every
single day from 1989 forward with the
intention
of only doing what was in service to the
people who were watching it is why no
matter where I go in the world on any
given day somebody comes up to me and
says I watched your show it changed my
life
I've been watching since I was 5 years
old until I until I went from DVR to two
VCRs to now streaming people watch and
were raised by that show I did a good
job of raising a lot of people I must
say and that happened because of an
intention to be of service so I live in
this space of radical love and gratitude
truly I have ai ai ai ai feel the most
beautiful life that you can imagine I
sit around trying to think of who could
have a better life and I will tell you
whatever you imagine my life to be like
I wonder what Oprah's doing right now
it's always ten times better than
whatever you think it's true and it's
because not because I have wealth which
it's great that's what money's fabulous
I love it and I get a lot of attention
and that's also good sometimes but it's
because I had appreciation for the small
steps the seeds that were planted the
map and flow of my life that unfolded
because I was paying attention you have
to pay attention to your life because it
is speaking to you all the time and the
bumps in the road and the failures that
pointed me in a deuteron new direction
and led me to a path made clear that is
what I'm wishing for you today your own
path made clear and I know that there is
a lot of anxiety a lot about what the
future holds and how much money you're
gonna make but your anxiety does not
contribute one iota to your progress I'm
here to tell you it does the opposite
look at how many times you worried and
you were upset and you didn't think you
were gonna make it through the block I
got that text a couple months ago
and here you are today
you made it and I'm here to tell you
that you're going to be more than okay
so take a deep breath with me right now
and repeat this everything is always
working out for me I want to hear it
everything is always working out for me
that's my mantra make it yours
everything is always working out for me
because it is and it has and it will
continue to be as you forge and discover
your own path but first you do need a
job yep
you need your job and may I say it does
not have to be your life's mission not
your greatest passion not your most
fulfilled self but a job that pays your
rent yes and lets you move out of your
parents house look who's applauding
because yes they are tired of taking
care of you and are hoping that the CC
fine education you've received is going
to pay off and it will it will I promise
you in ways that today you cannot even
imagine you know for years I've been
talking about and I've done a lot of
graduations that I do a lot of lecturing
talking at the table exchanges with the
girls and we talk about passion and
purpose and realizing your dream and I
realized that I was confusing them and
their expectations were out of whack one
of my daughter girls who graduated two
years ago came out of school with a job
that she previously intern she bought
her own used car
has an apartment she shares with Ron
only one roommate all with no help from
me and she'd only been working about six
months calls me and says mom oh they
want to give me a promotion but I don't
think I want the promotion because I
don't think it fulfills my purpose and I
said your purpose right now is to keep
that job your purpose is to do what you
have to do until you can do what you
want to do I borrowed that line from the
Great Debaters so here's the truth for
years I had a job and through that job
doing a lot of things that I actually
didn't want to do I got demoted and
discovered my life's calling so I was on
the air as a reporter my job ended when
I was 28 years old
but I've been working in radio got my
first job in radio at 16 was hired in
television at 19 and it was a job
because every day I felt like I don't
know if this is really what I'm supposed
to be doing but my father was like you
better keep their job so when I was 28
it wasn't working out for me on the news
because I was too emotional I'd go to
cover stories and cry because people
lost their houses or lost their children
I was told that I was going to be taken
off the evening news and put on a talk
show that was a demotion for me at the
time that actually worked out for me so
I would like to say that many times many
times there are things that look like
failure in your life and I want to clear
up because four years at every
graduation I've said there's no such
thing as failure well it is I've said
it's no such thing as failure it's just
like pointing you into a different
direction it does it indeed does but in
the moment when you fail it really feels
bad and it's embarrassing
and it's bad and it's going to happen to
you if you keep living but I guarantee
you it also will pass and you will be
fine why because everything is always
working out for you
so I realize this when I was in the
struggle of my life I tried to build a
network at the same time I was still
trying to do a show and I did not have
the right leadership everything is about
having people in the right positions to
support you and so I had to take a good
long look at myself when everything in
the media cuz all of my mistakes are on
the evening news or the CNN crawl I
can't do anything privately so in every
news story when every story is about
struggle struggle struggle struggle I
had to have a talk with myself and say
what is this really about what is this
here to show you my favorite question
when in crisis what is this here to
teach or show me Jeff Weiner one of my
friends and founder of LinkedIn says
that failure is what's going to Humble
you it helps you realize how fleeting
success can be at least traditional
measures of success because you realize
that to some extent how it is just
beyond your control and you invest less
in it in terms of the way you define
yourself success in terms of achieving
objectives in terms of manifesting a
mission in terms of manifesting a vision
that's all good especially if what you
do can create good in the world but to
the extent that you start to define
yourself through traditional measures of
success to the extent that that's your
source of self-esteem you're destined to
be unhappy because you cannot control it
Jack Canfield
chicken soup Soup for the Soul another
one of my thought leaders that I admire
says the greatest wound we've all
experienced is somehow being rejected
for being our authentic self and as
result of that we then try to be what
we're not to get approval love
protection safety money whatever that is
and the real need for all of us really
is to reconnect with the essence of who
we really are
reown all the disowned parts of
ourselves whether it's our emotions our
spirituality whatever we all go around
hiding parts of ourselves he says he was
with a Buddhist teacher a number of
years ago and that teacher said here's
the secret if you were to meditate for
20 years this is where you'd finally get
to just be your self but be all of you
so I've made a living not a living but a
real life from being true to myself
using the energy of my personality to
actually serve the purpose of my soul
and that purpose I'm here to tell you
gets revealed to you daily it is not
just one thing
it is the thread that is connecting the
dots of everything that you do so when I
first started television at 19 as I said
I was just happy to have a job but later
through experience trial error some
failures recognized that my true purpose
was to be an inspiration and a force for
good to allow people to see the best of
themselves through the work and the
stories that we were able to tell and so
that becomes my legacy I remember when I
finished the school and I had gone to my
mentor friend Maya Angela's house my I
was making biscuits and she was teaching
me how to make the biscuits and I said
my I'm so sorry you weren't there for
the opening of the school she said oh
babe I know it must have been beautiful
I said yes that school is going to be my
greatest legacy and she said you have no
idea what your legacy will be
I said oh no no my other school that did
the school those girls that's gonna be
my legacy and she said as she put down
the dough you have no idea what your
legacy will be and I said yes ma'am she
said because your legacy is every life
that you touch and that I repeat
everywhere because it's true it's not
one thing it's everything and the most
important thing is how you touch other
people's lives every day you're carving
out the path even when it looks like
you're not all your actions are creating
equal and opposite reactions which is
the third law of motion in physics what
you put out is coming back how you think
and what you do is already being done
unto you that is my religion I live by
that and so that is created a very
blessed and spectacular life for me and
I want the same for you if I could
actually teach a class on how to live
your best life it would contain all the
gems I've learned from all the world's
leading thought leaders it would also
contain some gems I have not like yes it
does pay to floss yes you do need to
look people in the eye when you speak to
them you need to keep your commitments
if you say you're gonna do something you
need to do it you need to make your bed
every day because when you do that it
makes the whole house look better but I
put and you need to not to bring your
cell phones to the dinner table I put
many of those little gems real gems from
thought leaders and a little book I did
with you graduates in mind because so
many of my girls were finishing school
with the anxiety of what do I do now mom
oh so I wrote the path made clear it's
my stories of figuring it out with gems
of wisdom from some of my favorite
thought leaders like Jeff and Jack and
Pema Chodron
they are totally and many others and so
since I know you just want to get that
diploma I'm going to save all my wisdom
for the book and make sure you get one
as you walk across the stage
and here's the deal I'm gonna hang you
the book I'm not gonna take a selfie but
somebody will be there to take the
picture and because you all all of you
and all of you showered and shaved and
came all this way to support I have made
the e-book and the digital audio book
version free today for the rest of the
day until midnight wherever books and
digital audio books are sold in the
United States in Canada you can just go
online and you can get your own digital
version of the path made clear that's
Apple or Amazon or Nilka Google Play or
Kobo so what does that mean that means
that you get a book congratulations
class of 2019
[Music]